this is no ordinary snake what makes it
so unusual is not its ability to slither
up a tree like this many snakes are able
to use their belly scales to push
against tree bark allowing them to
undulate upwards know what makes this
tree snake so unusual is its interest in
well one might say passion for becoming
airborne these are flying snakes they
fly from tree to tree why well probably
because here in Indonesia it's the
quickest most efficient way to get from
here to there the snake flattens its
body into a ribbon shape launches itself
and then swims through the air actually
since the snake can't fly upward it
might better be called a parachuting
snake of course two can play at this
flying game this is the flying dragon
lizard the snakes interest in the flying
dragon lizard is entirely culinary he
wants to eat it the flying dragon puffs
itself up as a warning
the snake seems unimpressed
or at least undaunted I mean a meal is a
meal is a meal sorry got a fly on either
side of the dragon's body are thin wing
like folds of skin supported by five to
seven ribs that extend from the body
with its wings extended it's capable of
flying for distances of up to 30 feet if
the snake is a parachutist but dragon is
a glider oh nice flight and great
landing and terrific self rescue